all right I think you're gonna like this
did Kerry Lake hire the worst lawyers in
the world for this completely bogus
attempt to steal the Arizona
gubernatorial election which she of
course lost before I show you the
lawyers remember what Kerry Lake said
yesterday we looked at this clip
yesterday where she was talking about
hiring lawyers our true Patriots we had
attorneys who did walk away because left
is threatening them with
a living and practice law and some of
our attorneys said look I got mouths to
feed I can't do this case I don't want
to be sanctioned so I I really love I I
got to a point where I said I'll take
anybody we'll take Better Call Saul to
come on in here yeah she'll quite
literally allow any lawyer to represent
her so let's get to the chaos
significant difficulties yesterday for
Kerry Lake's legal team they had an
issue with their witness list and then
they forgot they removed a witness and
then they try to call that witness and
the judge is like you told us you
weren't calling this person look at the
level of confusion among these lawyers
not exactly legal geniuses what happened
what he's saying that he's not on the
list
oh this is the best
so they're shuffling through their
paperwork now
hmm where is that list who's on the list
yes
they're saying he's not on the list
the list I'm looking at your honor does
show Aerosmith designated a witness if
you thought your honor wants to give me
a few minutes I can go through my emails
and
uh if you get what I was what the court
was given and I don't know that we
provided that list
I think
we also I think there was an email
communication from uh plaintiff's
council not exactly Clarence Darrow as
you can imagine continued problems then
uh where they now
um it just it just it's so bad look at
this that she works with Betty in
getting records from Maricopa County
okay in response to to foyer requests
your honor and you've also told me that
this was disclosed previously yes I am
your honor yes when was it disclosed to
oh I'm sorry your honored this last week
has been like four months
and I I if if you want your honor is
going to take me a good 45 minutes look
for our disclosures you're like we
stopped one second you're an officer of
the court I'm just asking for your word
if you tell me it was with it I'm
telling you it was disclosure you're
telling me within the last week yes
you're on right goes to this morning
something like that your honor that I
have created on two separate occasions
at their request that I give them access
to all of our records via a link so they
can go online and download them and I
can show this court that I have provided
them at least two links to do so
wait a minute
I don't want to waste a bunch more time
on this we've already spent a lot of
time on it I'm just down to the line the
entire the entire trial the entire case
and hearing is a waste of time that's
the little consideration which is
disclosure so they're not
shocked by this disclosure is different
than saying
here's here's here's where all my stuff
is you can dig it so the judge
explaining to the lawyer why it just
doesn't make any sense what they're
doing then they get into an argument
about like an exhibit number
75-year honor it's uh yours your 75r1 no
it's there's only one number it's the
Court's number that we're referring to
not mailing line yours is it's 75 and 75
is admitted understood John I say R1 for
their bit
got it very good 75 you're on yeah so
these are the people that apparently are
going to get the Arizona gubernatorial
election overturned so Kerry Lake's
choice of lawyers not particularly good
let's briefly talk about her choice of
experts I love reading I read every day
no matter how I arrange my schedule I
never have enough time to read all the
books that I want which is why blinkist
has been such an important part of my
life for years now our sponsor blinkist
is the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils them down into
an explainer that you can read or listen
to in just 15 minutes which includes all
the most important takeaways from the
book with blinkist I can absorb the
essence of 15 different books in an
afternoon so I can quickly gather
insights from all sorts of perspectives
make connections have those kind of aha
moments that don't happen so easily
which is why I feel enriched when I use
blinkist blinkist also summarizes
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers and with the
blinkist connect feature my girlfriend
and I can share one account share books
podcasts with each other talk about them
on the go and don't forget blinkus makes
the perfect holiday gift my audience can
try blinkist free for seven days and get
25 percent off after that go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is down
below